you
I'm going to show how to subscribe to
Microsoft translator and to connect your
subscription to a translation memory
tool like wordfast pro in order to
subscribe to Microsoft translator visit
the site data market dot edge or com
make sure that your region is set
correctly to where you are located so it
would so that you get the offers in your
currency search for translator choose
Microsoft translator you can see here a
list of all the different volume levels
that you can subscribe to ordered by the
number of characters per month that you
can consume start with a free
translation of two million characters
per month click Sign Up at this point
you have to log in with your Microsoft
account if you do not have one you can
sign up for a new account here if you
are a hotmail or outlook or Xbox user
you already have a Microsoft account and
you can use it
here you can review the terms of the
offer you can agree to it and click Sign
Up at this point you're subscribed to
Microsoft translator you still need to
create a client ID and client secret in
order to connect it to your translation
memory application visit your account
click on developers and register an
application
your translation memory tool is an
application in the eyes of the microsoft
azure marketplace you can define a
client ID however it needs to be unique
globally unique let's hope this is
unique you give it a name
you give it a client secret I suggest to
define your own
it must be at least 20 characters long
as a redirect URL you can give your own
website or if you don't have one use
Microsoft translator com but it doesn't
really matter
click create
and you have defined your client ID and
client secret you are now ready to copy
your client ID and client secret into
your TM tool to do this just click on
your client ID then you see the whole
thing that you just defined together
select your client ID and copy it and
paste it into the appropriate field and
wordfast the appropriate field in word
fast you find under edit preferences
scroll down to machine translation
choose Microsoft translator enable it
copy your client ID here go back to your
browser choose your client secret copy
it
paste it here use Microsoft translator
as a primary test out if it works okay
it works and now you are ready to use
translation in wordfast pro just to make
sure everything is secure sign out of
the issuer marketplace and you are done
and ready to use Microsoft translator in
your translation memory tool